we are going to talk now more about the
border situation in depth with the
former head of border patrol rodney
scott rodney thanks for being here you
retired in august of this year that is
correct thank you for having me brett
appreciate it this makes you the highest
ranking ex biden official to speak out
but you also worked in the trump
administration that's correct i started
as chief in february of 2020 and then
through the transition for the first
seven months of the bite administration
you've been at this for a long time
though i started in san diego in may
1992. it's kind of an important part of
my career though that's when uh the
whole mass migration issue is going on
nationally and then in 1994 is when the
operation gatekeeper got kicked off
and i had a front row seat to that as a
young agent that was the forming years
of my career if you will yeah so i'm 30
years as a civil servant dealing with
border issues primarily obviously you've
briefed both parties but you're not a
political guy
correct i've done my best to stay uh
nonpartisan i've obviously have not
hesitated to advocate for border
security
but i just lay out the facts
without without politics well let's talk
about the facts and
what has changed
from the trump administration border
policies
to the biden administrations now the
real thing that's changed is the focus
on border security in general and
acknowledging that border security is
critical to homeland security
and actually trying to control the
border
the messaging has changed i personally
participated in some of the transition
meetings
my staff participated in all of the
transition meetings uh we made it very
clear that if we dropped all of the
initiatives that had been put in place
over the last several years
that we would get an influx of mass
migration that we would not be able to
control the current secretary my orcas
he was part of dhs before
he was ran cis he he clearly understands
and knows how to control the border and
what needs to take place so if that's
all true then then what's the motivation
do you think that's where you get into
the politics i'm not going to speculate
on what anyone's motivation is but i do
know that they were briefed i was very
clear
there are people involved in this
process that have been involved before
and they're choosing not to take simple
common sense
common sense steps
to secure the border can you for the
average viewer at home articulate kind
of the difference about what would
happen if an illegal immigrant came when
you were border patrol chief
before january 20th 2021 and what
happened after with title 42 and that
was a health and human services
regulation for covet you got to carve
that that part of it out if you will
they would be
met at the border immediately
fingerprinted photograph for records
checks quickly and then expelled back to
the country they came through it so
during that time
the vast majority of people were quickly
expelled back to back to mexico or back
to canada
or other countries even where we had
flights taking place to quickly get them
out of the country and then keep america
safe
that was slowly chiseled away so
right after the administration changed
um there was
some messages that went out if you will
that we were no longer going to expel
anyone under 18 unaccompanied minors so
as soon as
there's any vulnerability that we
that we show or any certain class of
people that we carve out to be processed
under different uh different processes
that are going to allow them to come
into the u.s
that will be exploited we saw that
immediately with the unaccompanied
children a couple of other decisions
later there started expanding out
vulnerable populations family groups
coming through mexico that's
increasingly were getting released into
the u.s and processed under title eight
instead of 42. that's families pregnant
women
and suddenly it was expanding beyond
anybody under 18. and then that just
continued to expand correct and what's
the result of that the result of that is
the message goes out and then instead of
having
a couple of hundred encounters a day we
quickly went up to about six thousand
encounters a day
a little bit of misleading messaging in
the in the public today too is they
think this is just mexico or south
america
border patrol caught over caught people
from 150 different countries coming
through mexico into the united states
this last year before i retired 150
different countries different countries
coming through the border correct
it's basically just think like football
basically they fake a play over here and
the real play is going to the left so
when we get distracted with 15 to 20 000
haitians under a bridge that resulted in
several hundred miles of border having
no board virtual agents on it at all
that's where the cartels push the
narcotics through the criminal aliens
people that will not give up
we have over 400 000 documented got
aways people or incidents where people
cross the border and got away this last
year
and hundreds of miles of border where we
have no idea what took place that's what
mass migration creates
you're talking about the cartels and
moving
all kinds of material but specifically
drugs correct through the border
so this
look at the shiny thing over here
happens every day it happens every day
and it happens increasingly the more
that they can distract the more that
they can overwhelm our resources so for
example in del rio
the 100 of the border patrol agents for
a couple of days were focused on that
bridge
but we also keep forgetting that's a big
wide border mcallen is still out of
control yuma is getting overrun by
administration has claimed that the
thousands and thousands of illegal
immigrants that that they have released
into the country over the last several
months are being quote tracked
and that they have implied that there'll
be consequences if they don't show up
for their court hearings
is that true again it's a spin so i
can't say that it's not true but i can
say they're not all being tracked if
they you're just by manpower just by
manpower issues and if every single one
of them are being tracked currently then
that has to mean a hundred percent of
fugitive operations got shut down and if
they skip court i mean they're not even
really allowed to just go after them for
that correct that is accurate and ninety
percent uh don't don't ever get deported
how big a national security threat is it
that that border i think it's a real
real big issue so knowing that we have
400 000 documented got aways when we
have less situational awareness than
we've ever had before what we know about
every single one of those is they did
not want to meet a law enforcement
officer
they were not surrendering they were not
claiming asylum they were doing
everything they could
they probably paid extra to be able to
go through one of those gaps the cartel
controlled so when you hear secretary
mayorka say the border is as secure now
as it was before
what do you say that's just not true he
knows what's going on and he knows that
border is not as secure today as it was
on january 19th talk about the border
wall what were the
instructions after the transition of
administrations when it came to the wall
so presidential proclamation came out
and now it was a 60-day pause that
publicly available we're supposed to do
an in-depth study and then come up with
a plan going forward as border patrol
did its part everything that was done
within about two weeks
several briefings later
there really hadn't not been any
decisions made it went well beyond the
60 days
many of those projects today are just
still on hold so we're paying
contractors uh for a while it was almost
five million a day between dod and dhs
just to not to not build the border wall
there's
five million a day to not build the wall
to not build even though they have all
the stuff they have there are stacks and
stacks of border wall
panels there's hundreds of miles of
fiber optic cabling uh there's hundreds
of of cameras that were being installed
with that
that are just sitting
there's no action being taken so
what do they say when the briefing is
well this really helps us
if we could just plug this in if we
could just finish this thing what did
they say we're not building more well
there's no conversation there's not
there's no adult dialogue if you will
it's just
it's just a black and white decision
administration said we're not doing it
so we're not doing it that money is just
trickling away to those contractors for
not doing work each day
what is the border patrol
morale it's struggling right now it
really is struggling right now
obviously this administration doesn't
really support border security the
current leadership within border patrol
is doing everything they can to keep the
guys focused that the mission matters
when you heard president biden say this
it was horrible what to see as you saw
to see people treat it like they did
horses barely running over people being
strapped it's outrageous i promise you
those people will pay
they will be an investigation underway
now and there will be consequences
there will be consequences what'd you
think
i was dumbfounded
to take a word from somebody else i was
it was i was outraged that all of a
sudden due process
goes out the window border security
protects legal immigration and those
guys know it that's what they've been
doing and all of a sudden now due
process applies to everybody else but
not them and then all of a sudden our
horse patrol doing what they're supposed
to do which is prevent people from
illegally entering our home are now the
villains
so it's frustrating it's very
frustrating and do you hear that from
guys i've taken quite a few phone calls
it's very frustrating uh
the the early retirements are going
through the roof uh within border patrol
it worries me tremendously we're losing
a lot of experience rodney thanks we're
going to have part two of this interview
with rodney scott about the border
border security tomorrow shannon we'll
toss it back to you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else